on est le soir tard un petit tas
nouvelle conquête à venir manger chez
toi tu lui as vendu un plat délicieux
était talents de cuisinier seulement
manque de bol tu sais absolument rien
faire des nuls en cuisine et du coup tu
es sacrément dans la merde
heureusement monsieur drevet là je suis
comme toi rassure toi je suis le
cuisinier du quotidien je suis pas un
champion
par contre si faire d'autres trucs et
ses quelques astuces vont sauver la vie
aujourd'hui je vais te filer une recette
qui paye pas de mine que les français ne
savent pas faire qui fait voyager le
best of the best des italiens les pasta
alla carbonara les pâtes à la carbonara
et crois moi c'est pat elles ont
toujours eu un franc succès alors pour
des carbo réussi il te faut des petits
lardons ou des titres allumette au choix
des pâtes fraîches une préférence des
tagliatelles ça marche toujours bien du
parmesan et des oeufs
non ça je jette pas allez c'est parti
alors on récapitule des pattes du
parmesan des allumettes de1 oignons de
l'ail un oignons et de l'ail et si
vraiment nuls
tu peux les transformer en ail échalote
ça marche aussi
mais là vraiment nuls 1 à non non non
non et non et non
surtout pas de crème fraîche dans les
pâtes à la carbonara
il n'y a pas de crème fraîche la crème
fraîche ça rend la sauce vraiment fade
et c'est pas terrible en goût ces plats
sans saveur rien c'est naze
voilà avec qu'on va faire la sauce et
s'accroît moi c'est superbe
bon maintenant on va faire un petit peu
de maths attention c'est l'instant
intelligent il faut vraiment se
concentrer pour les quarts mots il faut
2h30 par personne citant les trois ça
marche aussi
mais tu auras plus de sauce et elle
risque de beignets un petit peu au fond
donc je te conseille les repas perd
toujours par deux s'il ya toi et ta
future conquête ce que tu fais tu prends
5e très fort en maths si maintenant ta
copine elle veut venir aussi avec une
copine
il va falloir en rajouter deux ennemis
là on est dans la merde donc par les
sept personnellement je remettrais 8 le
mieux c'est que ta copine qui n avait qu
une copine qui viennent encore avec une
copine tu mets 10e c'est parfait et ça
c'est pareil pour toutes la recette
c'est à dire que pour deux personnes
tu mets deux petites barquettes et une
barquette de pâtes fraîches c'est pas
des pâtes fraîches c'est la marche avec
tout type de patin t'inquiète pas c'est
pas grave si vous êtes plus nombreux
tu me fais toujours des multiples de
deux ter tu prépares un repas pour
quatre même si vous êtes 3 c'est pas
grave après que tu peux très bien
séparés mais tu auras trop de pâte est
passé lardons il y aura un déséquilibre
donc ce que tu fais tu mets soit 5 e si
vous êtes 2 si vous êtes 3 tu me disais
qu'à pêcher
tu fais à manger pour plusieurs au pire
tu lui fais un hobby bague et si après
le petit câlin du soir elle a encore
faim jean lui faire à manger des petites
carbo la nuit ou au petit déj si elle
est anglaise alors le principe pour les
autres c'est super simple tu me mets tes
5 e une fois que tu as tf1 que danton
récipient maintenant il faut rajouter du
parmesan le parmesan c'est la base de la
sauce permettra dans l'assiette aussi
mais pour l'instant on va en mettre un
paquet de dents on y va opération
parmesan voilà regarde moi le borgne
parmesan comme il est bon celui là tu
tartine monde tu envoies des grosses
giclée de parmesan formidable tu mets à
peu près la moitié
maintenant c'est l'heure du poivre alors
tu fais pas trop le port mettant des
sites mais tel que qqun boulin poivre
regard moi ça y'a plus qu'à tout y est
alors on récapitule cependant je mélange
c'est hyper simple 5 e pour 2 personnes
10 e pour trois ou quatre personnes du
parmesan voit la moitié du paquet si
vous êtes 2 si vous êtes capte on va
leur paquet par contre il faut un
deuxième paquet encore pour m quand tu
serviras tu me mets du poivre et c'est
tout surtout pas de crème sinon je tends
gueule ça c'est à proscrire la crème
c'est pour les mecs qui savent pas faire
les fatals à carmaux ça c'est la sauce
pour tes carbo et crois moi c'est super
bon alors écoute moi bien ça ça ne se
fait pas cuire site il faut en
casseroles savak aurait gueulé ça va
être dégueulasse
surtout pas en casseroles je
t'expliquerai tout à l'heure ce que tu
vas en enfer pour l'instant tu le mets
de côté et tu n'y touche plus si tu es
une grosse feignasse et que tu as
vraiment pas envie de s'emmerder à la
solution sinon on va quand même prendre
des minutes pour ça regarde moi commence
c'est beau ça
regarde-moi sa jacqueline comme c'est
beau viennent pas
et bingo à ton tour live ça c'est un des
secrets des carbo mais si tu es carbo
sont pas bien taillée elles vont être un
peu fade donc il faut y aller franco sur
lie ensuite oignons situe le coupe tu
vas le couper en petits bouts quand même
écoute monsieur fait lui confiance il
sait ce qu'il fait avec son union dans
ce sens et dans ce sens et la garde tous
ces petits bouts comme c'est merveilleux
pour l'ail par contre c'est hyper
important
tu fais des tout petits dés tout tout
tout tout tout tout petit bout si tu
fais des gros bouts dice est mort ça là
maintenant tu laisses surtout pas comme
ça je veux des tout petits bouts c'est
un futur conquête
elle croque dans la vie à pleines dents
d'une elle va refouler toute la soirée
et de deux c'est pas sûr qu'elle a envie
de tout rouler des pelles toute la
soirée non plus hein
puis de toute façon vous aurez
exactement la même haleine tous les deux
bonbons selon pas être très généreux on
à l'oignon on a lie au choix maintenant
à la base on a préparé la sauce on a
coupé ail et oignons maintenant il va
nous rester à préparer notre flotte
alors les pattes normal c'est entre 3 8
minutes ça dépendait pas de ça dépend de
l'épaisseur de la pâte les pâtes
fraîches ces trois minutes sur toute une
effet pas trop cuire il n'y a rien de
pire que des pâtes un peu molle sous la
dent c'est dégueulasse ça tue le plat
alors pour préparer tes pattes déjà il
te faut une casserole et portez lardons
une pole pour la casserole qui va mettre
de la flotte de danse aller là on est
bon goût un peu de gros sel hop ça pour
toutes tes base bingo bon ça va t'es pas
trop lundi maintenant qu'on est là on va
commencer à faire chauffer l'eau pour
faire cuire des pâtes
c'est l'heure de faire cuire c'est leur
nom bon on va procéder dans l'ordre
d'abord la cuisson de lardons ensuite
quand ils vont commencer un petit peu à
frémir qui va y avoir un petit peu de
gras qui s'est déposée en ce moment là
on va mettre l'ail et seulement deux
minutes avant de les retirer à peu près
quand tout est bien cuit on va renaître
l'oignon mais pas avant pour garder un
peu le croquant un peu de matière
[Musique]
pour la ces quasi moncuit j'ai mis deux
minutes avant mon oignons donc
normalement là c'est nickel si vous
utilisez l'ail et l'oignon comme ça
attendez vraiment la fin vous le mettez
une minute avant la fin que ça sera
hydrate et ça vous ferait un truc
homogène quand vous faites vollard dont
vous embêtez pas sinon vous pouvez
remettre un petit coup de poivre ici là
surtout pas de sel dans les lardons pas
de sel dans les lardons pas de celle
d'un les lardons sinon c'est du sel au
sel c'est dégueulasse à cette étape on
est prêt pour faire cuire les pâtes
je vous explique on continue de laisser
mijoter doucement on baisse un petit peu
le feu ne faut pas que ça crame on
laisse mijoter doucement et là c'est
l'heure de la tagliatelles trois minutes
pas plus pas moins trois minutes plus
tard et c'est maintenant que tout ce
jour les pâtes les lardons et la sauce
et on touille et on sert on sert minute
par contre les lardons dans les pattes
on met tout dedans et c'est comme ça
qu'on fait lescarbeau mon pote up et on
mélange ton mélange avec taiseux va
prendre la température des pâtes la
température des lardons ne vont pas
qu'aux réguler et vont de faire une
sauce onctueuse qui aura vraiment du
goût et si t'aime pas et beaucoup plaint
je te dis pas quoi pour le service tu va
racler les bords tu prends quelques
l'art donc tu va poser sur le dessus
histoire de finir la déco un coup de
parmesan et voilà le plat idéal alors tu
vois c'était pas bien compliqué tu le
fais chez toi tu goûtes tu me dis ce que
tu en penses tu mets un commentaire en
dessous et tu mets des gros pouce bleu
parce que je me suis bien décarcasser
faut se faire plaisir à beaune toi la
chaîne partager invite tes potes si
aussi sont en galère
à bientôt au salut